So now we know some ways to make comparisons.
We want to use them to make decisions--
to make our code do something different, depending on the result of a comparison.
The way to do that is to use an "if " statement.
The structure of an "if" statement is:
we have the keyword, "if", followed by a comparison,
we'll call that the test expression,
followed by a colon.
And then, inside the "if", we have the block,
and the block is the code that will run when the test expression is True.
If the test expression doesn't evaluate to True, then the block doesn't execute.
And, as was in the procedure definitions,
we know the end of the "if" because of the indentation.
All the statements inside the block
are executed only when the test expression is True.
The next statement that's not indented is going to be executed,
whether or not the test expression is True.
So here's an example of a procedure that uses "if":
We can define a procedure, "absolute".
It takes 1 input, which is a number.
Inside the body of "absolute" we're going to use an "if" statement.
We'll use an "if" test, where we're testing if the value of "x" is less than zero.
So that's the test expression: we have the "if" followed by the test expression, "X < 0".
In the Block, we're going to have one statement
which changes the value of "x" to be "-x".
The next statement, which will happen after the "if",
whether the test was True or False,
will return "x".
So what this does is gives us the absolute value of the number that's passed in.
If the number that's passed in is negative,
we take its opposite and we use its negation,
and then we return.
If the number is positive, this test will be False
so we don't execute the block that changes
the value of "x" to its negation.
We'll go right to the statement that returns "x".
So now it's time for a quiz to see if you understand
how to use "if" and can use it to define a procedure.
Your goal for this quiz is to define a procedure called "bigger"
that takes in 2 numbers as its inputs
and it outputs the greater of the 2 inputs.
So here are a few examples:
If the inputs are "2" and "7", the greater input is "7" and the output should be "7".
If the inputs are "3" and "2", the greater input is "3" and so the output should be "3".
If the two inputs are the same, say "3" and "3", the output should be "3".